hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play doorways hi
excuse me can you wait until I'm done
with my introduction thank you very much
ok so this game is one that I've been
looking forward to a long time I've been
following it quite closely and it's the
first in a string of really well made
horror games that are coming out on this
one just came out and then there's a
outlast which is coming out on September
4th and of course amnesia a machine for
bigs on September 10th so look forward
to a whole lot of scares coming up in
the near future so I got my volume
cranked up I got my lights turned down
I'm ready to go let's do this
Leroy Leroy I creep slowly into the cave
so that he don't die Leroy is gonna take
this cautiously press a key any key I
pressed it did that one key determined
in the size some cases these Psychopaths
must be found
the other agents couldn't get them but I
can do it
was that Alexander I just want to say
that sounded a lot like the voice actor
for Alexander from amnesia this is so
cool he's such a great voice actor he's
got that Rumble that everyone wish they
could have okay here's the credits built
right into this jump Crouch slow down
there's no sprint there's a slowed down
button which I'm gonna imagine that I'm
gonna need to do okay so obviously this
is an exceptionally well made game if
you've been looking at some of the it is
dark in here I cannot see okay that's a
little better yeah if you've been seeing
some of the indie games I've been
playing they're pretty you know
amateurish in design I mean concept
they're pretty solid but in order to get
a good game you need to have a sort of
design team oh hello the journey will
not begin until you are ready what do
you need a box to keep valuable objects
a place to locate notes letters and
other papers and a bag to put tools to
use when necessary okay so I'm guessing
I need to find him first right off the
bat want to say sound incredible this is
amazing right here I feel I feel very
very immersed which is always a good
sign I mean the graphics do look pretty
good and that is important for some
horror games not paramount to mascara
the player but it does help with the
whole immersion process okay so anything
over here that I could use nope alright
I don't have any sort of a portable
light source to carry with me but
hopefully they'll be hello you something
Crouch to go through narrow pass holding
down see well it's dark in here
alright so something hold Mouse one over
objects to push them in hold mouse two
to attract them if you found an item
focus on it and press Mouse one to pick
it up
okay oh hello
that glowed ah there we go got it relics
press are I'm pressing are oh hello why
am i carrying that okay I'm done I'm
done
can that go away now what is going on
get another there we go I didn't want to
look at it anymore
frankly it was kind of disturbing okay
so I got an Academy Award for super
acting this is back in the Stone Age of
course when we're all crawling through
craves craves you heard me so there's
two more branching paths over here and
here what have we got
can I go through there okay no the door
is blocked up ah I see you want me to go
through this one alright I have to
comment again that it's exceptionally
dark I apologize if you guys can't see
anything but I'm pretty sure this is
intended and also I've got the volume
way up move forward and jump at the same
time using space you got a buddy whoop
I foul I miss jumped I have no sprint so
I just got to cut this one close oh I
see yeah there we go all right what do
we got a note to keep my notations notes
what do we got I don't know what I'm
doing in splices it a dream it feels too
real for that whatever you say buddy I
don't care just get the things and let's
carry on for our journey yeah right yes
light up this thank you wow what love a
thing do I need I'm hoping a lamp or a
flashlight of some sort but we got
No okay where am I going
I can barely see really wish I had some
light what have we got here make your
own way to get to the top the top of
what I can't even see when I'm climbing
up I guess I got out whoa what did I do
okay that pushed it I don't know if I
needed to Boosh it do you guys hear that
I heard some okay anyway I'm gonna pull
this over here where I think I see sort
of a ledge rocking there we go okay up
there up there up there up there got it
nailed it
all right a backpack for my items good
good good good great great done dude
so that's cool I'm guessing that's what
goes on the door so that I can progress
forward okay let's just carry on our way
and we can finally get out of here what
is this the walls in escape seemed to be
closing in on me but something about
this place seems familiar I feel calm
for some reason my belongings or what I
think are my belongings are here
okie dokie whatever you say mister epic
voice man puts my voice to shame by far
okay how did I get in here I don't even
I can barely see okay there we go
alright we got something okay I think I
got what I need now I can move forward
hello
thank you very much what does that say
now you have found all you need to check
your inventory and find a way to pass
through the door you open your inventory
by pressing tab you got it buddy
let's look in the items cuz I swear
there was a thingy thing Boop
yeah there we go and did the trick is
gonna be good yeah I can't wait oh yeah
go right into the darkness there are
things which are burned into my memory
my name is Thomas Foster and my duty is
to bring these four Psychopaths to
justice I just hope to resist their
sadistic influences the corrupted Minds
could overpower my own and find them
I must how how do they do that how do
they do that thing that you just said
they did corrupting minds how does that
happen are they telepathic why am I
doing this and why am I alone why is it
dark I don't know these are all
questions I wish I had the answer to
last I do not
press a key you got buddy is that gonna
need to do every chapter one the forest
of steaks mmm sounds delicious
but I'd rather not go in there sounds
horrible actually actually yes
sounds very horrible very horrible okay
now we're getting into the heart of the
game which I'm assuming jqj Gibbs in
England 1962
professor of history yeah suspected for
the kidnapping of 17 people yeah here in
the adjoining areas of cabin owned by
his family okay the missing persons have
in common
certain indirect factors religions or
pagan practices for a nationality that
are not reason enough for the local
police to start an investigation
doorways link the profiles of the
victims to the topics in which professor
Gibbs specializes okay all right what
the hell are doorways what do you mean
by that that doesn't make much sense to
me although I could listen to your voice
all day long okay all right then
oh my goodness oh my goodness do you
guys hear a growling I think I do
might be some animal trying to get to
those steaks okay which way do I go and
I see a note over here hello
I'd arrived at the crossroads I knew I
had to keep going and follow his steps
if I wanted to find the professor but I
found something about
the place absolutely terrifying I felt
trapped oppressed by those dark veils
and I knew that I won't be able to stand
a single minute lost in the darkness I
need to find a light source as soon as
possible indeed II do I do so let's do
that
how about that thing that we do how
about that I want to do that so which
way do I go and how do I go I dropped
off a ledge to get down here can I steal
this what was that something happened
something changed
I hear that growling okay I heard
something yeah I can't go back okay
let's go this way then no one honey
thank you
I don't any am i dead get out of the
darkness and illuminate your way out I
couldn't identify - damn torch okay can
I have this thing can I have this thing
can I have that please please let me
have these things the right here I want
them I hear the things in the forest
weren't there two paths just like two
seconds ago wasn't that a thing do I
have anything in my inventory
no how about my relic maybe if I swing
this in the light will somehow
illuminate my paths no what
what the hell am I supposed to do I was
owned Aust there were two paths just a
second ago weren't there I'm not crazy
it said crossroads and now there's only
one way what do heck oh maybe I crouch
ah
that's what I do no I'm sorry I'm
getting on the end the light I'm in the
light I'm very sorry okay what is this
Oh
look a torch just like every one of
those that I could have grabbed a while
ago okay can i light it foosh yeah yeah
baby yeah it's the stuff all right looks
great that's so much more better okay
let's go into Luther
it goes out what does it go out get it
okay let's go
No crazy psycho ladies no crazy psycho
ladies who crazy psycho ladies no guys I
got it
which way do I go
which way do I go what do i do I go and
I need to reboot I'm gonna wait till I
go getting refulgent okay let's go
20-week oh this was like a one-way thing
this was a one-way thing when there's a
thing over there and crouch like boss
yeah Boosh okay carry on moving forward
not gonna pee my pants not gonna do that
okay all right but we got at that moment
I felt I was retracing the steps of many
others like me how did they overcome the
mortal chill that lurks in the dark I
don't think they did souls went astray
and got lost forever in the shadows
because there was another horror that
scared them even more that made them
flee into the dark woods yeah what was
that he fled the place I'm entering
that's not good then don't do that don't
do that thing that you want to do I'm
trying to tell this guy how to do his
job and he's not listening to me push oh
boy no there you go what is that what
was that it was hangman people give me
my torch foosh it foo [ __ ] damn it food
stuff everyone maybe I got a foo [ __ ]
somewhere else can I please have some
fire totally lovely just added oh
there's one down over there okay excuse
me thank you
all right moving forward let's go the
way that I saw the hangman men hanging
meaning men you know I would have
thought
you can't just fade out black on me like
that I think I'm about to die I really
think I'm about to die didn't I just go
this way isn't that what I just said
I've no idea it kind of all looks the
same
what is this what is this what is this
bigger torches what is this what is this
okay balancing on the beam it's dark but
I'm assuming that I'm gonna be okay I
can't really see no thank you
no what are they got a job yeah nailed
it nailing it okay doing good so far
jump down jump over Oh is there anything
over there I can't see wait no hang on
aha there we go I was about to jump into
the precipice of death all right I want
to do that what kind of shoddy ass
bridge is this
this is horrible there's no way that
this would live up to code no engineer
would be proud of what he did here okay
am i I can't say I cannot say I really
wish I had some light go go go go go
I can't see I can't see I can't see
where there's wood oh my god
I don't want it it's completely forecast
dark what do I do
all right about you what do I do there's
no other way
I got wait yeah houki dokey oh you go no
oh no oh no you shut up you sharp and go
to hell how about how much farther do I
need to go this is ridiculous this is
the worst bridge ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever goddamn hell am I going I cannot
see oh no no please tell me I died off
fudger nutters that was baloney
das baloney ID baloney I had a whole
haka baloney okay so I'm not supposed to
or I'm supposed to fall straight down to
the mighty my death hey God I'm gonna
see something here wait wait this might
be terribly stupid of me
this was dot dot that's gonna help a lot
yeah that is much better okay I couldn't
see a damn thing cuz all my brightness
was way down whoops my bad oh I see
that's not a thing okay and that I don't
want to jump on to cuz it'll it'll break
ah I got a hurry
okay I just got a hurry across that and
then I should be fine okay I got this
it's all under control now
you guys are probably yelling at me like
you are you're so stupid just turn up
the damn brightness how dumb can you be
the answer your question is I can move
okay no how about no I'd rather not
thank you going go to hell go to burn in
hell
okay I don't know what that is but I
don't want anything to do with it I want
nothing to do with it I can't say that
it's a whole lot I'll go that way I
won't go that way I bought it
oh no I got a good loop yeah hey did I
make it I'm mad at I made it I think
okay so anyway how do I save how do I
know if I've saved I don't want anyone
na na oh I didn't like my torch
Oh Han an idiot okay I'm terribly
terribly stupid okay I'm terribly stupid
let's go into the darkness this game
creeps me to flip out my lights
give me my light I'm sorry no no I keep
apologizing for everything I'm hoping
that the ghosty goos will one day
forgive me for all my transgressions
okay so I don't know how we're heading
towards but I'm assuming that it's
important it might be it a doorway okay
what the hell is this what the hell is
all this okay
all right then okay when's it gonna turn
today oh good they open the doors for me
am i inside that criminals mind I'm just
curious if that's what's actually yeah
Oh suddenly I'm going faster now why
what's suddenly I'm running oh okay
oh I see I'm gonna get it eventually cuz
I think there's nothing behind me okay
maybe not
I'm sorry okay I'm sorry what do i do do
I keep trying I don't think I keep
trying I think that's the wrong course
of action I need to find something to
open the door they need to find
something now
oh sorry what what happened
I didn't see anything oh it was a trap I
walked right into it
what was it I didn't see anything
oh I see you made me look up it was on
the ground a DA yeah here we go
I see another trap I see that one we you
made me look up it was on the floor some
part of the trap okay whatever
no bus all that oh no wait that's just
decoration okay ah denna a gun
I'm so stupid at this hub there we go
all right yeah looks like I got to go
back through what I did before already
you up just ah come on
ah balderdash okay
come on get this gotta get it
gotta get a good OOP huh I guess that's
why they sped me up because they knew
that I wouldn't be able to get through
it otherwise I see it's just a pattern
what oh I see nah yeah woo yeah okay
this is really close cutting it here all
right we got it we got it got it got it
got it got it got it got it okay this is
one messed up Castle man okay alright
okay
nose normal I should probably take my
meds I must be set in some sort of an
evil area okay this looks important
there we go
what did that do I can't see it
occasionally locks my vision in place
and I don't know what that means
hundreds of people were tortured in this
timeless place yeah that's my question
swear that there were no buildings or
ruins like this in these woods
yeah many of the victims were prisoners
of war but some some are much more
recent from those I can see
I can look through their eyes all of
them are males prisoners yes but there
were no wars being fought when they were
caught okay they were kidnapped one by
one and brought here by the professor
what you see himself as a righteous man
an emissary of God I think he sees
himself as a crazy psycho bonkers guy
that's just my personal preference okay
I am all out of time for this game man
this looks like it's gotta be a great
game I mean it's really incredibly
immersive it's startling and creepy and
they're random noises that just pop off
at random times which I like I think I'm
just barely getting into the start of
this so I expect this to get much much
it's already pretty creepy but I expect
this to get much weirder as time goes on
so check the description for a link to
the game it isn't free unfortunately but
for something of this high production
quality you gotta understand they gotta
eat somehow so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
oh dude dude dude dude dude there's a
dude cut yeah yep you're dead yeah
you're dead I don't don't even try it
don't even come in
haha